okay hi everyone uh welcome to another
design review meeting for wolverine
language
this is a part of our incremental
language design
series looking at a variety of topics
different every time
um
and uh let's see first up is threaded
oh it should be in the prototype build
exciting exciting
um
i thought we were going to call it
threading
threading or threaded
robbie yeah
but by the way rob you you you sound
like you're in some kind of underwater
cave yeah i know i'm sorry my my headset
is broken
um i have one that's been on the way for
a while and i think it's just played by
the christmas rush but okay no matter it
is what it is
okay
let's go to the prototype build
um just think of all those elves who
have who are who are going around with
headsets now because yours hasn't
arrived yet never mind
okay
christopher is here also okay great
all right so let's take a look here
at
this is exciting threaded
that's very useful
that's a very nice thing
okay so now if i go
times threaded that'll do the right
thing
if i go
threaded this
plus this plus threaded
a
b happy happy what about if the first
one is is uh if you do x y z plus this
plus threaded do you know what i mean
yup
no
is it always i mean has have you sort of
worked out if this is like always
associative and stuff like that
it is not
but but jose and i tried to make it as
associative as possible
well what's an example i mean do you
know of a simple example where it's not
just so we can see how bizarre it is
um i've got a weird thing that we could
do
what would it do if it did this
is this just absolutely flamingly
hopeless
what
no that works i don't think the problem
is there
why why did that work
i mean okay so what is threaded
on its own why wouldn't it work
right it's the same innermost dimensions
right
so but this this is a key thing that
jose and i work out is so that that if
if you have threaded
and
and the levels are all positive or all
negative which they're all negative in
this case then we return a threaded
object
so it can persist
if all you have are threaded things
why do you want to put the minus one
explicitly there why can't that just
return threaded without the minus one
um we possibly could in this case but
but in cases say if you mixed you know
if you mix two different dimensions
there so if you had you know ap bpp you
know is it you had a two dimensional
array in one of those we have to have
the level to to make it
wait a minute why wouldn't it just
default to the lowest level of the of
the
possibly i think you're it's it's
possibly correct steven we could in the
in the cases where the dimension the
thing you want to mention that the thing
inside
matches the negative level we could
probably eliminate that negative level
i i think you're right
okay
okay minor thing yes um
so what's up what's an example where
it's not uh associative
um oh jose had one i can't remember one
right now um
so just for certain heads or is it
arbitrary
just just set do do set attributes of f
listable
okay
changes the behavior of all listable
functions right now do do f of threaded
of you know whatever
well give it another argument
right okay
right so f is now taking
right f is taking the place of plus or
time so if you take one of your
arrays from one of your matrices from
your plus or times example
right you'll get the right thing with f
in place of
times or plus
right
plus or times is just a it's just a hit
there's nothing special done for cluster
times
so by the way i mean there's a bunch of
weird cases i'm not maybe i'm not sure
if there are any problems here but
what if you do threaded of threaded
right so it'll thread over and then it
will thread again with the inner thread
if that makes sense
bob did you consider that case
no
no i mean it'll probably work i'm not
sure it's really what is what is
threaded what is threaded item potent i
mean and if i do threaded a b
threaded of threaded of a b
well if the outer threaded doesn't go
all the way to negative one if it only
goes like negative two or something
then
then you could imagine that the inner
threaded could
then do something oh
yeah
that's pretty weird
well that didn't even do what i expected
because it didn't uh
didn't do anything yeah right it didn't
right it's just like an arbitrary
expression because it wasn't a valid
threaded or something exactly well
so what this should have been is a
threaded this should have been
a
yeah you have to have a list it needs to
have a list in in the first argument of
the thread in order to do anything
yeah okay
that seems right
yep okay
how do you get rid of a threaded i mean
do you does normal get rid of the
threaded or does do you just say first
to get rid of a threaded
you just say first
okay
i mean it's not it's not like an
alternate representation of the list
it's a totally different thing
right
now how does it does it play nice with
splice and things like that
no
[Music]
it's not the threading like operation
right it's a modific in place
modification of an array
i mean right nothing right that no
nothing nothing disappeared too quickly
exactly right exactly so
okay but but you can't put
wait a minute when you put a
splice
if you have a splice in here
i don't know we'll just evaluate away
right
yeah yeah see the point the point at
which we get to dealing with threaded is
is
is in the evaluator after the arguments
have all been evaluated
it's not it's not hold first
right
by the way i mean just
you know
does it um
does it does it already have some stuff
so that it it it's faster and
like uh
does it
does already have sort of the
optimizations that basically you can do
uh you know packed array operations
without having to transpose if you know
what i mean or no but but it it does not
it does not do that yet that's i wanted
to get this design set before we started
doing that and and you know that's sort
of some of the talk i had with tom in
the comp in the compiler meetings about
having a threaded type
um
would would allow us to start doing that
um i mean mark would have to put some
stuff in the runtime library to do that
but that's relatively easy stuff
this is really a lovely function i mean
this is really so useful if you just
want to you know
yeah right
i mean yeah no it's it's it's it's super
useful and i think the case you wrote
right there is probably going to be the
most common case where you you have
thread of some vector and you want to
add it to a matrix
yep
yeah can we talk a little bit about the
explicit level specs because i think
that's worth hashing out okay
yeah
okay so let's imagine so are you saying
here
if i were to say array
a
you know 2 2 2 2 2 or something
then i would just say plus
threaded
x y that will go at the lowest level
right it goes to the lowest level
if you look in the if you look in the
section on threaded array in we actually
have some tables showing you exactly
where it goes depending on the level you
put in
my god
is there something problematic about i
mean it seems to me that this is look i
mean the only problematic thing with i
think with the level n is we don't have
a we don't have a mean for threaded
blah level zero
i see okay hold on so let's let's see if
we go level n here
and we say n
up to
four
if i'm not mistaken
am i not seeing anything because this is
just it's just gonna be the same
this is the same in all these cases
isn't it
no it's not
right the x's and y's are going to be
laid out differently
oh yes so they are yeah right yeah this
one
right so this first one should be the
normal
the first one right should be the normal
listable case right
level one
yep
okay
okay so that's the positive levels now
what is the level what what would level
zero mean
level one is okay so you're saying
standard less stability is level one
yes because that's kind of at the the
level of the elements so you combine at
the level of the first yep
yep and minus one is the default for
threaded and it's at the lowest level no
it's not see that's that's the other
slight subtlety if it's a vector minus
one is the lowest level but if it's a
matrix
minus 2 is actually the lowest level
because this is one of the design
decisions jose discussed at length and
that is we should not allow threaded to
create extra rank so so we don't want it
to be like an outer product or something
so we don't allow it to create extra
rank
yes
so
just for concreteness can you do that
same table only with minus n so we
i presume we'll get the same results in
reverse
or is there some subtlety i'm missing
should get the same result i mean i
can't i can't see the results with this
framed thing so
you can't see what the frame thing will
how what would you like me to do
well i don't know i can i can read those
tables but maybe that's because that's
what i'm used to i don't
[Music]
um
okay what what did you do here you maybe
say for those tables maybe you can say
part all comma all comma
one or something so that you get just
the x's and the y's out okay okay fine
okay so let's say this thing here
i do that
i say part all
comma all what are we saying all
try try all come on all come all one
maybe i'm not sure this will actually be
that much more clear but
i think we need another all oh yeah
and now we could say
yes now you can see the difference
okay
by the way this might be a useful thing
to have in the documentation possibly
something like this
you should use an f that you know you
should use the listable function that
isn't also orderless but yeah
okay so this is
level four
which is also level minus one here so
what was this thing about minus two i
didn't understand that
okay so suppose suppose you put in
thread a two-dimensional array
yes
in here
okay so so this so what we're saying is
in this thing here
then the point is that the lowest level
of the two-dimensional array better hit
the lowest level of the main thing
precisely rather than it appending a
level right
i see so in that case
threaded comma 4
fails why does that fail
i see because if it were to attach
itself at level four it would have to
poke down yet another level
right on yeah
yep
okay
so why does minus one not work
isn't -1 what you would expect to work
minus one so so so minus one
is that's the level of the top of the
the level of the top of the thing inside
of threaded
i mean level minus
this is similar to the pause and oh
pause for an inset that is you have to
say both when you stick the inset in
where does the where in the destination
is the insert going and then what in the
inset is going to that place in the
destination
yes in some sense yeah
so what we've got is within the threaded
we've got a
in a sense what we could be doing here
it's a bit like transpose we could be
doing something where we say this level
in the threaded
is going to be put at this level in the
in in the receptacle so to speak
yep
right so i guess
another way of saying the same thing is
the minus two means
that the
highest level of
the contents of the thread that will be
placed at the minus two level of
whatever array it's being combined with
okay so what it's really saying and
maybe we should have an explicit
notation
is threaded
of blah one goes to minus two
in a sense
yes
level one in the threaded is going to
level minus two
in the destination
and the default is one goes to minus
depth of x xx
is that right
uh
yes that's right one okay so this is
level one in the threaded is going to
this level
in the destination
and
so in a sense one goes to automatic
where automaticus depth of xxx
is the default now is it useful would it
be useful to give these two things
explicitly i mean that's what we didn't
do with transpose and it was a mistake
so to speak we eventually now have
transpose explicitly
using
you know saying what both the source and
destination
if i'm not mistaken levels are
so my question is would anything other
than one in the left-hand side here be
useful probably it could be
sure i think it could be and if you
wanted
um
so the default is always then so
if if we say comma n
that's equivalent to one arrow n
right
and if we say nothing it's just
obviously equivalent it's equivalent to
automatic which is equivalent to minus
the depth of the of the content of the
threading
yeah
i guess you could also think of the
default as minus one goes to minus one
why
yes that that's correct you could think
of it that way as well
i'm sorry i didn't understand that why
the lowest the lowest level of the
x-axis oh i see it put the lowest level
of the expression
monkey with this object with this thing
here this is a reasonable default
yes yep
which is an argument to be able to
monkey with this left-hand side
so
what is the way that you would do this
similar operation using
what would you be doing you would you be
using transpose or flatten or join we
don't have a join at
well you can't specify the
level of the joining it's not super
flexible but right because it requires
sort of uniformity
but
it's it's it's really i mean it's it's
really hard to to actually do this
without the the threaded
right i mean i think the thread that
it's like a
transpose and and do the listing and
then re-transpose to get back to where
you want
you can
normally do it
do we like the name i think i like the
name threaded seems like a pretty
reasonable name for this
i think it seems pretty intuitive
okay
yeah so so so so on the error i mean i
think this arrow syntax and it's
perfectly reasonable so so if we just
give a number do we assume which do we
assume
that it's one those two
um
unless it should be
look the thing that's going to give the
least errors
is if it's the bottom of the threaded
goes to a certain level in the in the
destination expression isn't that right
that's the most likely to be correct
something that's going to poke its nose
out into the wilderness so to speak uh
to mix many metaphors at the drop of a
hat
seems
like it isn't the best thing
in my argument we the default is the
thing that is most likely not given
error
or maybe it's maybe it's too obscure if
it's the bottom of the um
um
well what do people think
if you're threading single vectors
there's not going to be much of a
confusion
right
if there's
the xxx is deeper than the asso then the
expression is thread with can it
possibly succeed or is it always a
failure it fails okay
say it again
if the xxx is deeper
than the thing with which you're trying
to thread it it's always going to fail
it can't make it deeper on the bottom or
out the top
right we just we don't we don't allow
that right because because then you're
getting it things like outer products
that that's simple and understandable
and yeah i like it
okay so the only issue is is it one
arrow blah or minus one arrow blah
[Music]
right so the thing on the left is
referring to the threaded right yeah the
thing on the left is referring to the
innards of the threaded it's saying
where does the where does level n in the
well okay if i think it should be one
is in my opinion okay
well so it's saying
i think my
why did that not work
okay so if it's i goes to j it says
level i inside the inside the threaded
payload
is placed at level j
inside the container
right
okay
um
it's probably most intuitive for is one
by default
um
i tend to think so
right
uh okay
algebra of threaded objects what do we
have to discuss here
or did we already cover this
i think we kind of already covered that
okay non-rectangular cases
i'm i'm basically advising against this
um because
i just i don't think we care i i don't
think we can let's let's implement it
for the rectangular case
and if it turns out that there are some
obvious non-rectangular ones that are
useful let's consider extending it
okay fine
um
i think this is just wonderful i mean i
i don't really have much else to say
about it
um and hopefully you're going to have an
efficient implementation of the whole
thing
yeah well eventually i mean i mean
the current implementation actually
works if you do a big packed array
matrix plus a you know plus threaded of
a vector
i think it's
even even the default immutation is more
more efficient than transposing and
adding and transposing back
okay okay well good so and we can do
much better than that but yes it
eventually it eventually will be i mean
that
you know that'll
that'll take some work from mark but
it's but it's relatively easy to
to do it from the from the top down so
so it shouldn't be a problem
okay
excellent
this is a victory
i mean i think this is uh is one of the
important things that we wanted to
achieve with the raise and this is you
know and we got it
good stuff okay and what are we so so so
the final question is what do we what do
we do with if somebody gives thread out
of blah level zero
what would you expect it to do i mean
how is it going to work i think i think
we should just give a give a message
saying
how could it be how can it knit onto how
can it knit itself onto level zero
it can't because we're we're not
allowing it to increase or decrease rank
so
zero giving a message
yeah i think so i don't see how
how could it do anything else other than
that
because as you say it can't do it
without changing rank so to speak
um
okay sander notes on our live stream
this looks like it'll be very useful i
agree completely
i was asking also can algebra with
threaded object with symbolic levels be
done
that's amusing
that's amusing but i think it's it's
it's at this point surplus to
requirements that is if the levels are x
and y
can we actually do sort of symbolic
combination of threaded objects well one
of the things we already have to require
for the algebra offended objects is that
the levels specified be both the same
sign
in a sequence of threadeds
right why
if if you don't
then you then
then then you you you can't you can't
produce something that would go against
a particular so if you say threaded of
blah blah blah comma minus one
plus a disembodied threaded i agree with
you you can't possibly combine that just
embodied oh no in in a in a whole
expression against a array yes you can
have levels but but in this algebra
we're going to produce a threaded thing
we have to have the same summary yes but
can you in fact but oh you are doing
that here yes so this
i mean this
doesn't work with symbolic
levels
but that seems very ups well i don't
know if it was x and x plus one
maybe you could do something
is it worth it
well the question is if x
yes we if if if
if we can't do it with an x and a y
because you don't know if x and y have
the same sign
but you could do it with an x and an x
plus one
it strikes me as pretty deeply simple
and the thing is by the time we get to
this
we're kind of at the point at the point
we're kind of evaluating the listable
operation so i think it's a very
marginal benefit yes
i agree
i think this is wonderful
could possibly do it and you know in the
context of our symbolic tensors right we
could add support you know assumptions
on
on the symbolic level and whatnot and
maybe there are simplifications we can
do i don't know if jose has thought
about that at all
i don't think his eye is here today yeah
he's not here today no he's away if
anybody's thought about it would have
been jose
um
doug is commenting on this
horrifying fact that's because this is a
raw rational number
and this is
b times c to the minus one
yep uh i think that's just the way it is
yeah
um
okay the symbolic tensor case does seem
interesting i don't know what this
corresponds to in terms of
i mean in terms of physics-wise tensor
notation what on earth is this
silence nobody knows i it's a it's a
slightly weird operation in terms of
physics type tensors
right it's
i mean it's sort of it's sort of
i think it's
including
sort of dummy slots but i would have to
think about it
um just a question about naming and
things how does this relate to threading
layer
who knows so ask the machine learning
team i'm not sure
um
okay sandra is commenting that threaded
comma x plus threaded comma x can
combine that is true
whether it's worth combining them is not
clear
with two identical threading levels
i mean we don't tend to do that
does does splice have a have a level
spec of some kind
i don't think so
right i've got a question one of my pet
peeves is when people need to insert in
a function
you know sequence at at okay so this is
a case let's just talk about this for a
second people want to insert
a thing here that's going to unpack into
x uv
how should they do it
and what people often do is this
horrendous sequence at at least uv
right what what do we actually want them
to do
i mean i don't think you'd only want
that if you don't want the actual
splicing right i mean you would just do
sequence of uv
unless the
no no assuming this is coming from
somewhere else
it's coming from somewhere else that's
coming from a variable we say
something like you know
with q equals uv
yeah
then this
okay i absolutely hate this maybe there
could be a second argument to splice
that's basically the head that it would
splice into
but why doesn't splice just type into
the you know enter in the top level head
anyway no because because the whole
point of splice is that it's inert
unless it's in a list
otherwise it's impossible to do anything
with it exactly
i mean it's it's the exact the reason it
doesn't is precisely so people don't
have to do splice at
yes yes yes okay yeah
yes exactly but but anybody if it had an
optional second argument where basically
you tell it one or maybe a pattern for a
head that you would like to splice into
with the default being list
then
maybe that could work
so in this case it'd be f
yeah yeah
yes i mean
and then you could throw this splice
around any way you want and it would
only explode when it when it uh
you know when it hits an f
i mean
the reason i hate sequence why do i so
hate sequence attack
perhaps it was because i mean this was
one of the
semantic disasters of smp was its analog
of sequence which was a function called
np
for rather bizarre reasons um which just
sprayed garbage everywhere
and sequence i mean what do people think
about sequence and it's you know
sequence has always been a slightly
shadowy
kind of function
i mean the function that that i mean
i think it only gets
it only it's only justification for
existing is that it kind of has to come
up in some pattern matching contexts but
otherwise i think it's it's
it's very weird
right but this case
i mean how do people feel about this yes
i mean this is really useful people use
this for options
filtering all over the place
yes
and it works
although although honestly i mean that's
probably the most common use that is
that i've seen is also options but yeah
but it's also in principle unnecessary
because options pattern if you're if
people are actually an options pattern
correctly then it accepts any nested
lists of rules
so
right
i mean uh
so i mean
uh
if if you're doing vector calculus right
you might use
uh well i guess you don't you don't
necessarily need the sequence at that
right you do
f triple at or or some such um
[Music]
yes i don't think you'd use this but i
mean the thing is
this is a rapper
that means
what the heck does this mean it means as
soon as this is evaluated unpack
yourself in whatever you are contained
in
well that's what sequence means right
the ad ad is just delaying the creation
of the sequence until the function
actually starts evaluating
yes as opposed to leaving it as a thing
which will explode on contact in
anything
right
somehow
yeah sandra is commenting that that he
often uses the hash
yeah i mean a construct like this which
is i think more civilized
i mean that's equivalent to this kind of
thing i mean this is widely used
and the question is and and now and i'll
point out he's still using an ad so he's
essentially doing the same thing is just
sort of
i i don't see that as materially
different
right well maybe bite the bullet and
decide that sequence attack is okay
but but why does it need to be at at
i'm confused why couldn't there be a
function there that it's just an at
on cue
that it's kind of like a head
well it's because it's it's right the
head of q is list or something well
right but assume assume it's always a
list assume q is always a list
then can there be something which is a
pure
which doesn't chop the head off
to do this something called like d list
yeah well it's like splice melt list
well i mean i i think i think well
suppose we maybe could implement it
using up values not sure but
it uh
right i mean the reason we use sequence
is that sequence has special meaning to
the evaluator and right we have
attributes about
sequence hold and whatnot for things
that need to be prepared to deal with
sequence specifically
well in other words the hack of a equals
sequence of blah blah blah
not
uh you know having not having the
sequence explode inside the assignment
function
or rule or
you know various others and obvious and
things which are hold all complete of
course also see the sequence
explicitly rather than it having
you know melting away
um right but what would it take to have
something which melts with an at sign
rather than melting with an attack
do you see what i'm saying i mean if if
q is a list
sorry
right i mean i think we'd need special
handling in the evaluator
um yeah okay i mean and i'm not sure i'm
not sure that removing one ad is really
okay ignoring the implementation issues
i'm just trying to understand the
semantics
if this was okay so what we believe
would be a workable thing is is this
yes
yeah and that can that can just be done
with an up value i think
right but my question is
what
i don't quite understand why is this
something i'm confused about the
semantics of this
you don't want it to ex
i mean
okay explain why
why
the whole point is imagine you have
something like um here's an example you
say
um
f of x comma y comma if
some condition then
two otherwise splice of blah blah blah
okay
you don't want to explode inside the f
yeah i mean that's the whole point of
splice is that you're going to pass it
around before you put it into the to the
list or the expression and otherwise you
wouldn't use splice okay but but so what
is the issue here the issue is somehow
at some point it finds itself just sat
in an arguments how did how can it tell
the question you're asking is how does
it tell the difference between the if
and the f
right how does it know when to explode
right and the point is with the sequence
at right because
um
you know if is hold rest
right it's only going to um
[Music]
right that that sequence will only come
into being and and then splice away
if that clause is actually evaluated
and right so you're changing sequence to
apply and therefore delaying the
evaluation until the clause is actually
selected
now with splice
um
right it would still be inside the f
inside the if um so it would sort of
i think run away
not entirely sure but i think it would
run away unless you had the comma f in
there
okay hold on sandra is making the
comments that there are two differences
between sequence and splice
sequence is verags
splice takes a list
yep
the reason that we're at atting is
because of the varexness
and we could perfectly well have a
version of sequence well
it's because of the vera arguments but i
mean i think it's also the i mean the
reason that that sequence is bad is not
just because you write out it's because
you can't use it i mean you can only
write that the point is is that
okay so the reason why like when you're
passing the the the cue you know if you
write you know sequence out at q
you can't pass that sequence at at
around you can only pass the queue
around and you have to run sequence at
the end
right yes i mean so you have to know
that it's
well whatever i mean it just seems like
it seems like having the uncontrolled
explosion is really an important problem
i think that's the most important
problem with sequence
right and you know that's why splice
only disappears inside of list
right but my question is
okay what is the signal that tells
sequence to explode in this case how do
we think about that what what's the
signal that causes this to happen
it's just the argument oh it's i mean as
long as it's not at the top
level i mean it always explodes doesn't
it
well no not if the function is sequence
fold okay but ignoring that case
what makes it
during the evaluation sequence because
the evaluation sequence is depth first
[Music]
right yeah so that apply evaluates
before right arguments are evaluated
before down values are consulted
therefore that sequence at
will oh yeah i've got a way to think
about this guys look the basic point is
what one wants sequence to do here is
something pseudo-lexical
you don't want it to do something
dynamic
because it will you know as you handle
the bomb it will explode
rather you want to place the thing
so to speak
before
right the whole point here is this is
essentially lexical
you want the q to be exploded
inside the f but not when it's passed
around
yep
so my question
perhaps it's too weird
is is there a lexical version
could there be something which lexically
as a rapper where you say this thing
here
and
literally within the f
you know lexical explode so to speak
of q
right well if the down code of lexical
explode is sequence at q then yes
i mean of course that won't work inside
of hold functions but neither does
sequence at q
nor does splice for that matter because
splice also goes through the normal
evaluation sequence
of sequence as an actual head is that it
disappears inside of hold functions
which are not hold all complete or
sequence hold
apparently in python there's a single
character that that does this operation
to unpack arguments
from a list presumably
um
but
so my question would be assume i mean
what will be the problem in having a
function
i mean this is like splice basically
except that i mean we could have like a
a two sequence or a splice into or
something that
you know basically just evaluates and
returns to sequence
or an unpack for that matter
and i think unpack has too many other
meanings
well okay but i mean this is
you're saying splice into
or maybe it's spliced into
well i don't understand
yeah i mean
okay but but the the idea would be so if
we had a function that does this what
does the function do if it's nakedly
used
does it explode or not see that's the
problem it should not explode
it should only operate lexically
if you just type this and have it
hanging around somewhere it shouldn't do
anything
okay how does it deal with this case
here
well it would be fine that case would be
fine right because it would only
evaluate if you actually
because f is hold or is hold on
right right
well
okay but but that case like this
this
python unpacking thing will will
presumably fail miserably in the case of
the if
because presumably essentially a lexical
unpacker
um
well you know i'm not familiar with the
uh
with the python thing right but you know
right we can either do things
strictly lexically which is essentially
what sequence does
right you know if you do a sequence of a
b
or a sequence at list a b right that
gets literally inserted modulo
attributes
and
or there's the spice model which goes
through evaluation and
works precisely
in the same cases as sequence at
well if you're ending up in a list
i'm sorry i'm really confused again what
is the semantics between this case how
does it know what is its signal to
explode
that it's insanely evaluation
it's that it's inside of a list no but
it's not inside a list splice i
understand i understand how splice works
i'm talking about generalized splice
okay
how does it know in this case here if
this is
g splice generalized splice
okay
how does it know
to
and assume that the if
you're claiming that the only way it can
know
is through when it gets evaluated
right and well it would need to be i
mean i don't think a generalized place
can work unless you and and
you know have the f inside of it
i get it but that that's look basically
the question is this is setting the fuse
evaluation sets the fuse for the thing
to be uh you know
explode if it didn't evaluate the fuse
is not set
exactly
okay
so
the question is
it is it is horribly dangerous
to have something where as soon as it is
not inside a hold
it explodes which is what's happening
with sequence
and we've had to put various kinds of
uh you know pat you know
you know protections like sequence hold
to prevent that being
um
uh being included
right i mean so
so that's the point we have something
carrying it around and having it explode
when it's naked so to speak doesn't make
sense
so the question is what other signal
could
this thing have
to say
you know after it's come out of the if
i think i think it's right that the only
way to do it is to say if you find
yourself in this head
well i mean i could imagine others i
mean you could have an attribute a new
you could introduce a new attribute
that's you know melting
that if any time it's in any melting
head it unpacks
yeah yes
yeah but but the default for for a user
function will probably be that you want
that to happen
is there any other signal that it could
get so in other words let's say it's a
in this case one signal is look at the
head
could it get anything from looking at
the other arguments for example
could it have any kind of default here
of what kind of functions it would by
default splice into
and see what the other arguments would
by i mean you could we could certainly
put in like a list of heads there
or maybe a pattern
so if you know the head matches this
pattern
um it it splices into right so blank
would explode everywhere
right and would be completely useless
but maybe but no
maybe blank question
question mark uh you know attributes
equals uh
listable might be useful for something
well blank would be the same as sequence
yeah yes right splice of cue comma blank
would be just like sequence that hat
which is not so terrible because that
you know
in lazy programming you could do that
but i could have some sort of smart
automatic where it's looking for like
data structures sort of things
right where generally it would want to
open up
that's a reasonable point things that
are unlikely to be logic structures are
more likely to be data structures
yes but in any case it sounds to me like
we should implement a second argument to
splice we've had some other comments on
live stream let me just look at some of
these here
um
let's see
um
brian mentions late binding which i'm
not quite sure what that is
uh
i can imagine what that is i'm sure i've
heard of it
uh
dan is commenting maybe we need a
shorthand notation for sequence attack i
think that's just sweeping
something even further under the rug
um
and my
thing that gives information
hold on here
um
okay
uh to sequence
um
function that works
like this what is this doing
args of head
what the heck is that let me just see
what is this doing
it's a function called args
oh i think the args
that's given the contents of anything
how would that help us
oh i see so
right so if you if you define such a
function that's the function you could
put
right if that is the splicer that's the
splicing function which will unpack
anything whether it's a list or anything
else
right
so it's kind of like a splice but it
doesn't need a list i mean because
because normally in splice you would
have to say splice list at
you know another function f x y
if you wanted that to work
if you wanted to take
those things and i mean melting them
into an outer f is a flatten operation
let's see
next
says maybe it's useful to have splice
only into the head of its argument what
does that mean
oh
that's an amusing idea
that's that's like
what happens with thread
where thread
will only thread things
something for sense if you put a cd
you know around this slide you know add
more arguments after the
splice
express
right so that that is essentially
that's saying splice is acting as an
auto flattener
splices is treating f as temporarily
flat
if i'm not mistaken
right
yes other than the fact that flat
doesn't actually affect the valuation
but um
right it affects pattern matter no no i
understand it it's it's
but it doesn't matter morally that
statement is correct i'm just pointing
out it's not literally true
but it does affect evaluation f of f
you know for a flat function f of f of x
is f of x
right if i set attributes
f to
flat then it is the case that f of f of
x y z
is that
all right yeah
this is an interesting idea this should
be started in my view because splice is
otherwise going to do nothing it's just
going to error out if it's head is not a
list
um okay
let's see
yeah blue is saying give it a way of
saying when it explodes yeah but this is
the whole problem is what are the
signals
you know during the evaluation process
there are different signals for what's
going on and
it's not clear
that there is a
you know the thing is being evaluated is
the only clear signal
well look i i think we've got two
possible ideas we've got the second
argument of splice which i think should
be studied and we've got the possibility
of auto flattening for a non-list
function inside splice
and by the way
this will be completely semantically
uh you know coherent with the fact that
if splice takes a list inside it's it
automatically splices itself into a list
makes sense
okay so can we can we assume you guys
will take this
yes
the study of splice who did who created
splice
i think it was jose in combination with
constantine
okay so nick can we
can you take this please
yeah i will check with jose when he's
back in and we'll go okay more detail
but both of these things so if you think
it's reasonable try implementing it okay
okay
um
our next
section here which we should try and
take a few minutes on is is the horrible
world or the wonderful world depending
on how you look at it of general
utilities yeah so this is an inventory
of the current system functions that are
still living in the general utilities
packet they i think there's probably
universal agreement they need to be
migrated
fine that's that's an implementation
thing it clearly needs to be done
um and basically i've kind of broken up
into categories uh planning on breaking
up some of the list manipulation stuff
and talking with danny about taking lead
on migrating those the technology i'll
take
so the question is what from general
utilities do people still use
and the one that i think is a commonly
used is module scope
do you agree with that or not
anybody want to comment on that what
does module scope do is that the one
that like finds all the instances of set
and then makes a module out of it i
think so i think it's an auto auto
moduling thing
it's an auto localizing function
i i think it was about to become
obsolete with new code assistance
features that basically do that for you
so perhaps it's a problem that's going
to solve itself
so perhaps there's no more to say about
those
the other one that i i use the only one
that i the two that i use frequently are
print definitions which
probably shouldn't have a top-level
version
and um
the monitored map which is probably
about to become obsolete
yeah i hope monitored map is going to
become obvious yeah i use a lot of
progress monitoring stuff in general
utilities
that should be absolute soon
ensure directory i use a lot
what's that
it uh
it's what i think create directory
maybe ought to be yeah it is called
insure directory
okay it's you know created intermediate
directories is true
and um
uh what else is there's some other
distinction between that and create
directory um if it already exists it
doesn't give away
i think
okay i think that's what it's called um
yeah if it doesn't it doesn't create
noise if it already exists
right because create directory gives a
message
yeah so
it's not groundbreaking but i use it
anyway i'm sorry my target option for
create directory like create directory
overwrite target arrow uh
falls or something i'm not sure does
create directory have an override target
option
i
thought it did but i don't see it listed
so either we
said
it should or
um well i guess the question is do it do
we really mean overwrite here or do we
no we don't it does not mean overwrite
yeah
do you care if there was already one
there right it's kind of similar to what
override target is but maybe not exactly
but it's one of the messages that the
system issues that would be first
to be quieted if you had some sort of
noisiness control
well okay so so this is
so
the the desire there is an option to
create directory that says
i don't care if the directory is already
there it's all good
is that
correct
right
i mean or is there should there be
another function that is called wait
since when is create intermediate
directories true the default did that
change recently
that last note i thought i thought the
default was false
i
i think it's been true for at least a
few versions okay okay
um
okay but so so i think what this
highlights is
uh
i mean there must be lots of other
create functions
are there not other create functions
like a file for example let's create
file
and what does it do if the file already
exists it issues a message
and
yeah but all directories are just
directories right
what do you mean by that in that
if
it's identical i mean it could be empty
or not empty but the directory itself
is
your point is that a directory's only
existence is its name
so that's not quite true because it has
permissions and things like that that's
true but create directory doesn't have a
interface for that
right but so your point is
are there other cases where
merely to have the name
is to have created the thing
boy it reminds me of of on our physics
project the atoms of space so to speak
merely the only thing they have is their
identity
um
okay in any case but this is a directory
is something
so your point is this is not a very
common case because
usually when you say create there's a
question what's the content but there
isn't in this case right
but there are other cases where that
happens i bet there are other cases with
channels and things like that
like create channel if the channel
it is merely the name of the channel
that affects it
um i'm sure it's unlikely you'd be upset
that it already exists when you're
trying to create it
yes the only case where you'd be upset
is where there's content you want to get
rid of the content
right
so i mean it seems to me we need an
option that represents
uh
you know
it certainly can't be called existence
warning
that would be very way too weird
um
i mean it's about well one possibility
is we just quiet the message and
at least in the case where you specify a
name by default
um right because because your point is
nothing different could ever happen
right in other words the fact that the
directory the only way that you would be
confused
is if you thought you were making a
fresh directory no no there's particular
if it's empty if it exists and it's
empty
there should not be oh yeah i guess
that's the point right if you're
assuming that the directory is empty
then
then you actually do need to know
whether it's freshly created or not
it's it's likely that you want you'd
care but
yeah
i think a lot of times very well care
because
you know that i can imagine all kinds of
race conditions with parallel things
where it's creating a directory and then
something else is creating it too i
think you want to know whether it
already exists in general
um
i mean somehow it reminds me of needs
versus get
you know get will always get it needs
only if it's needed
right i mean i yeah i have a lot of
scenarios where i create a directory
with a predefined name and then i create
files in it that are uuid based and i
know they're not going to collide and i
don't really care if there are other
files or i just what would happen if we
had a thing called needs directory
yeah we have insured directory and just
general utilities
that's why i'm using it
it doesn't seem like the right name but
sure sure directory needs i mean i just
think needs is you know needs of a
context
yeah
the term needs
is a context thing in my mind
well but needs directory would be if you
see that in a piece of code needs
directory blah
then it says created if it needs to be
created just like needs gets it if it
needs to be got
and otherwise be happy i i know i think
the present uh sounds wrong to me i
think needed directory is
why i mean you're going through the code
you're running a piece of code and from
there on out it needs the directory blah
blah blah but we don't necessarily i i
think it sure is about your name what
what precedent do we have for you know
we're saying what will happen in the
future
right we will need this in the future i
don't think we have a precedent for that
it's about either the past or or the
present
that's something in the present um you
know get
well i'm sorry why does this why is this
any different from needs of a context
needs of a context says load this
contents in if you need it
if i'm sorry if you have to load the
context load the context explicitly
otherwise this is simply saying for code
that has run after this assume the
context is in there
similarly here
assume the directory exists
for code that's run after this assume
the directory exists
yeah i i suppose it's just
i i propose that i mean the other people
can let's let's
you know consider this
let's see what we think about it but
that would solve uh
um
that would solve bob's problem right
right and and and by the way bob uh
create directory has defaulted to create
intermediate directories goes to true
since version six so okay
it changed but it was a little while ago
okay okay
that was in 2007 or something yeah
before we move on to tally buy i was
just going to mention uh i didn't have
it in the notes there but valid property
queue from general utilities is the most
used general utilities function in the
kernel startup code
which basically
returns true if a given element is in
a specified list or if it's false it
gives a message and says blah is not a
valid property of x
it's an argument handling thing that i'm
guessing it looks like it's mostly used
in signal processing and audio and a
couple of other places as a convenience
exactly properties
valid property queue
in general so what's what's the syntax
so this isn't talking about your kind of
properties that you do when you're
communicating with the alpha server no
it is specifically
so if you load general utilities and
look at the usage message it
has a breakdown of it but it's basically
um
so this is basically a message maker
yeah it is a
way to set to conveniently use a
properties framework without having to
do your own
message handling
it seems like it's basically you know
verify these input arguments for
but where would you use the properties
framework oh and it's trying to do its
own pluralization which i think is
wrong
[Music]
probably
but yes i think it's
well so let's take this and see if we
can understand how to make a better
version of it i'm not quite sure i
understand why
uh
right i think that the point here is
that it's you know producing broiler
plate code when you uh
right if right if you have sub values
which are you know can be a bunch of
strings then this is sort of using the
broiler
error handling
but right probably need some thought
right i mean look there's a general
category of thing which is a function
has failed or a function is going to
return unevaluated and you want to
generate a message i mean look this is a
topic we should revisit this is the
whole guarded evaluate business right um
all right so let's we'll put that aside
let's just see if we can hit one or two
more of these
taliban
so there's two parts to this being uh in
the function repository no i never use
tally anymore i always use counts
yep
yeah and so
the the second part of this is that the
counts by
example here
or the tally by second example has a
third argument where it specifies which
of
the instances of the matching function
you return so the difference between
those two outputs oh i see i see i see i
i mean what i normally do is i map
i take the result and i map whatever it
is over it
yeah
well i mean maybe this is this is the
same we talked about this in some other
meeting i mean about how there's there's
a whole class of association functions
that need some option like merging
function or something like that that
basically tells it you know in the
process of constructing this association
when you have repeated keys what should
your merging function be
so maybe that's exactly here right where
the default is list in the case of
of something like counts i think the
default is usually last
actually for counts it's not it's
nothing it's but the the um
sorry what i meant is grouped by yeah
group by the second argument you can
give a rule and it does it something
like this well yeah yeah group by has a
whole argument structure for
representing this though
representing what sorry how how to merge
keys
yeah oh actually i guess it doesn't have
a well
i think group is actually a little bit
different because group by will never
have um key collisions will it
that's the whole point
yeah it's it's it's it's keys
no it it it produces a list
right which is all the things that sort
of collided in the keys so to speak
right but the thing is like look at a
function like association or um i think
it's called association map
and it's second usage
right so here's a very common case that
that that i use a lot is that the second
usage if you set f to reverse that
effectively lets you you know switch the
orientation of all the rules right to
the the value of many yeah i think yeah
well i think association map is terrible
um because first of all the first two
usages have sort of nothing to do with
each other
the two usages have nothing to do with
each other
and of course
except for an incredibly small subset of
functions
f you're going to end up with an invalid
association
and or
right you might just silently lose keys
right
well that's the big the big thing i i
mean
i won't i won't speak to whether or not
the function overall makes sense but the
silent
silently losing keys i think is the big
problem here and i think there are a few
other functions that do that too that's
why i'm just saying if there was an
option here there was something like
merging function where you could set it
to something other than last then you
could make it so it doesn't silently
lose keys or at least you could
you could optionally make it not throw
away the keys i can't agree with you so
in that second example there
oh you moved on the first the first
usage is perfectly good and it's a great
function and right you shouldn't be
discouraged because of the second usage
right but if you change that reverse in
the middle example to f and then see
what you get back and yeah
and considering we have key value map
which does this but just doesn't wrap an
association at the end
well but that's the big that's the big
problem
it's very i mean this is a fairly common
operation where you have keys and values
and you want to basically reverse them
and the two ways you can write that is
you can use key value map and then use
association again or i think the better
way is if you say
um
uh
normal and then you say group by
last arrow first
but
both of these sort of have the
disadvantage that they i mean that they
kind of converted out of an association
then back in and it's you kind of have
to go through a list of rules for them
at some point which is a little bit
annoying right which sounds like an
argument that maybe we need a reverse
association function and just deprecate
or
ignore the effect just silently
disappear in the middle of the night the
second usage of association map
or whatever
maybe we should find out whether there
are other uses of this but look the idea
of having a merging function we already
have a thing called merging function i
think it's the same concept
that we'll just decide what to do with
multiple keys with multiple
elements with the same key seems like a
sensible thing for this and other
functions
same with keymap keymap is another one
that really needs something like that
oh right
yes
right i mean anything that messes around
with keys needs a merging function
because otherwise colliding you know
newly colliding keys will
kill each other so to speak
or same with association thread looking
to see also yeah i mean anything that
constructs an association or otherwise
changes keys
right well so it could be a key merging
function or it could be just a merging
function maybe it should be called a key
merging function well i would argue to
be merging because it's doing exactly
the same thing that the function merge
does
all right
well so okay
so fine so let's let's investigate
making it the emergent function can we
bring that to another meeting nick can
you take care of that yep yeah i'll work
with edison on that okay all right let's
we maybe we get one more and then then
until's really minor but it's
i don't see why we shouldn't have until
anybody object to it i mean it seems
like something that one occasionally
needs it's an obvious it's pretty
obvious what it does
yeah i i like it i mean in most
other languages i've seen this called do
while
but i mean
that's a very weird term so maybe until
it's better yeah i think do while it's
not a very sensible thing
until
well
do well as the other way around that
this is until
you hit
right which is what do while oh right so
this is reverse there's two there's two
differences between this and well right
one is it
does it first and the other is it's not
in the
test
yes
it keeps doing something until something
is true do while would do it first like
this but it isn't the inverse of the
test
right okay yeah
so we do we like the concept of until it
seems useful to me
until
yeah i like it
all right i don't think if any reason
the name would collide and i talked to
danny about it and he seemed on board so
i guess the i think the only real
question is the order of the arguments
right so in your traditional do while
right you you have the body and then you
have the condition
um
but while
while has a test in a body so this
really should be the same thing right
well i mean do while you in some
languages like in i think
yeah in like various you know versions
of c that have do while
they the whole point is that they they
signal that it's running the body first
by having you write while with no
condition and then after the while ends
you write do and then you write the
condition
but
that is a little bit weird maybe
sorry so what what happens here so the
point is that until
sorry you're you're running the test
first right no
that's the whole point so that this is
the the basic cases is um
you know you're going to be running
you're going to be looping over this
thing but maybe the test isn't deep like
here's a common case that that i've had
it's like okay you start with you know
some list right and you fundamentally
want to run it until the list is empty
but before the first iteration the list
starts as empty so you need to run one
iteration to populate the list before
the while loop kind of
prunes it down so that's when you do
something like this where you'd say you
know that way it runs the first
iteration and then it does the test
right so you'll notice that the usage so
sorry didn't mean to cut you off but i'm
just pointing out that the the usage
message right there in the second line
says that it performs the action
prior to the termination test
right
so maybe the order of arguments should
be reversed
it's not a clear-cut case but that's my
information hold on a second so you're
saying
until a body come a test
i mean with the name until i think it
kind of makes sense to reverse the
arguments because while it's like while
test do body as opposed to
do body until test
right
yeah
i think this requires a bit more
discussion we're not we're probably not
going to nail this right now
uh
i think yes i would tentatively say i
don't really know what the other similar
functions
it might also be worth surveying a
little bit like what other because i
think
there are several different names for
this construct in different languages so
it might be worth looking at yeah let's
find out what they are see if anybody
has a
um
take after
you know here's an operation that i do
all the time
which is find the position of the
maximum in a list
we don't have anything that does that
right
i mean there's some wfr functions that
do it it's take largest of list
um
take largest of list arrow index comma
one
yeah that's pretty hard or ordering
comma minus one
ordering comma minus one
first element of ordering comma minus
one yeah and also first element of the
the take
uh you know take uh largest by arrow
index
yeah but this is in the distinctly
obscure category have other people found
that they want to do this i mean is this
oh yeah yeah yes i mean one argument i
mean they take largest with the rule in
the first argument is a little weird but
i i've it's weird i mean i mean i know
how to use it so i use it now but it's a
little weird right and by the way an
argument for why i mean
there is a dis
there is an actual advantage to the take
largest as opposed to ordering which is
is for example sparse arrays sparse
arrays work with technologists but they
don't work with ordering because they
can't really work with ordering
in general
why isn't there a position largest
which is the take largest which is
simply equivalent to take largest with
that weird index thing which i had
forgotten existed
maybe maybe i'm wondering if there could
be a more general version of this
yeah i mean we have position largest in
the function repository
i mean there is a more general position
by
i guess not i mean
if you had some i mean maybe a more
general thing is just position of uh
you know
position of list comma
f of list right but yes that's what it
really is
yeah
right position in list i mean that's
what that's what one wants is position
although of course it's
position is one of these very unsafe
functions and you have to tell it to run
at level one with head zero falls but
yeah
would it make sense as a variation
i don't know that that's necessarily
true
right i mean if i i i i would frequently
use this uh on the rays not not just on
flat lists okay well then maybe not
level one but but certainly uh but the i
take largest in ordering those only
operate on level one i think defaulting
to level one is perfectly reasonable
here
um
anyway yeah go ahead
yeah yeah nothing
um
anyway this is another function we
should be discussing
there's some kind of position largest
or
uh
unfortunately i mean one really wants a
position largest buy
or position
we have position index which is
different but
you could conceivably
i remember position index but i can't
run what it is
so it gives back a
initial association
and by the way i think his position
index is also one where it might be nice
if it has a i think there have been
times i've wanted to have a second
argument where you can do things like
either the depth or maybe the you know
which things you care about
but
yeah
all right we should wrap this up um
yeah we'll bring back a set of
talking points for another meeting about
position manipulation or position
operations
sounds good
okay thanks much everybody and uh
mary whatever
and um
uh thanks to folks on the live stream
and see you later mary